[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID ARONCHICK: Hi, everyone.
Thanks so much for coming.
I'm David Aronchick,
PM here at Google,
working on a project
called Kubeflow.
And we're here to
talk about how you
bring machine learning
to multi-cloud hybrid
environments.
Particularly as an entire
stack where it's not just
thinking about the
machine learning
workload but the data and all
the other components as well.
I always like to start
in this very basic way.
Everyone has a different idea
about what machine learning is.
In this case, machine learning
starts with a question.
It always starts
with a question.
And so you might take
a sample question like,
how much is my house worth?
And then you come
up with some ideas
about how you might think
about how you would structure
the answer to that question.
Well, maybe it's based on square
footage, number of bathrooms,
location, whatever.
But on one axis you
choose that question
and on the second
axis that's where you
should choose your house price.
In this case, you go out
and collect a data point.
Well, if it's this big it's
going to cost this much money.
And then you collect
some more data points
and then you collect some more
data points and eventually you
get a line.
You draw this line and then
you answer your question
using all that data on
the line you've collected.
You say, OK, I have 2,100
square feet, my house is worth,
I don't know, $339,000.
Not in San Francisco of
course, but you get the idea.
So congratulations, you're
a machine learning expert.
With that, you can leave, we'll
have certificates at the door.
But of course, things
get complicated.
And in this case,
you could have things
like non-linear groupings
where you have things
by neighborhood or
things like that.
Maybe it's multi-dimensional,
maybe things change over time.
The reality is that that is the
essence of machine learning.
Where that first thing is
clean, linear regression.
Do you want to sound very
smart among your friends?
It's not a line, it's
a linear regression.
Machine learning is a way
to answer those questions
that you start with
without explicitly knowing
how to get there.
You collect a whole
bunch of features
and then you ask the system to
come up with an answer for you.
At Google we've
done this as well
and we had great
success around this.
Google obviously hires some
of the best data center
engineers in the world.
We're very, very proud
of how efficient we are.
We measure everything in
what's called Power Usage
Effectiveness.
So these are people who know
everything there is to know.
They're using renewable
power, they're
using the latest technology.
And what they want to do is they
want to be the most efficient
around this electricity, to
stick all this electricity in
and get the most
amount of compute out.
And they have a
lot of ideas about
what makes a difference
here but what
they decided is, why
don't we associate
this with machine learning?
We'll put all the features,
all the data we collect,
into the system and see
how we can improve things.
So what they did was
they graphed everything,
they turned machine learning
on and the graph came down,
and then they turn the
machine learning off
and it came back up.
And again, these
are the best people
in the world who thought
they knew exactly how to make
the system run
great and they were
able to get massive
improvement by associating
with machine learning.
We say this and
we as an industry
do a terrible job around this.
Because we see this-- we
show off these great signs,
oh it can solve cancer,
detect heart disease,
massively improve efficiency--
and people say it's great.
Except it's also
very, very hard.
And it's not just hard
because I'm bad at math.
It is hard because
there's this massive gap.
Most folks are collecting
data and they don't really
know what to do with it
or how to structure it
and anything like that.
And then they want to move over
and get to that ML goodness
but there's lots of
pain in the middle
and let me tell you about what
some of that pain looks like.
The reason is is because it
basically comes down to this.
You really today
only have two options
when it comes to rolling out
a machine learning pipeline.
Excuse me.
You have do it yourself,
which is great,
except you have to
set up from scratch,
you have to integrate with
all those legacy systems
and make sure things
are working properly,
and eventually, when it comes to
migrate based on your business
needs--
and there's always a
reason to migrate--
you have to go and you
have to do that all again.
That's a huge pain.
It does work but it
takes a lot of work.
Or you could go hosted.
Hosted it is fine in
those first five minutes
but then you have
the next five years.
You have all of
the things that you
had to deal with on
the left, integrating,
dealing with legacy, plus
hosted is single cloud only.
And the reality is is
folks are not single cloud
and I'll get to
them in a second.
To be clear that's not
all hosted solutions
but it's certainly the
most common situation.
Haven't we heard
this story before?
And the reality is we have.
This was the story when
we first introduced
Containers and Kubernetes.
The idea was that everyone
was out there rolling
their own bespoke solutions
for rolling out workloads,
for doing service
discovery, having
things componentize
and work together,
but that was not efficient.
Things wouldn't work
as you moved from cloud
to cloud, on-prem to cloud.
Things wouldn't even work
within different zones.
Containers and
Kubernetes gave you
an explicit, declarative way
to roll out your applications
in a way that made sense.
In Austin at 2017 we
talked about Kubernetes
being not just a platform
for rolling it out but being
really extensible.
Letting you take Kubernetes and
extend it in a way that makes
sense to you.
And that was the essence of
what we called Cloud Native
Computing.
Using that platform
of Kubernetes
to extend it in a
very elegant way.
As a result, you
saw this huge amount
of uptake of what's
called Cloud Native Apps.
These declarative, highly
microservice oriented,
highly distributed systems.
So what we need is
Cloud Native ML.
Cloud Native ML looks
like the following.
It is composable--
it lets you piece
a number of pieces
together based
on your business requirements.
It's highly portable-- it
lets you move from place
to place very readily.
And it's highly scalable-- it
takes advantage of the fact
that you now have effectively
unlimited compute.
By this we mean the following.
First, composability.
Most folks when
they think about ML,
they think about starting
with just building a model
and that's true.
Building a model is
obviously a core component.
But it is just one component.
A standard ML pipe might look
much more like this, where
you're spending a bunch of
time doing data ingestion,
analysis transformation, then
finally you get to your model
and you want to do
distributed training.
And finally you have to
roll it out production.
An ML system needs to
support all of these things
in order to be production ready.
Second, you want it to be
portable and portable looks
like the following.
First, when you think about
your overall stack of compute,
it's obviously not just compute.
CPU cycles are just one thing.
You might have any of the
following associated with it
where that entire pipeline
that I described before,
is just a portion of that.
But Multi-Cloud is the reality.
You could have this great stack
that looks awesome in one place
but 81% of you are likely to
have multiple of these stacks.
And not just one multiple stack.
In fact, the average
person has up to five.
What that looks like is, where
you have this experimentation
workload running, potentially
on-prem or on your laptop,
you might have a
completely different one
when you get to training and
a completely different one
when you get to cloud.
And that now just multiplies
your overall matrices
times three.
I know what you're saying,
this might not matter to me.
You're wrong and I can
prove it in one exercise.
Raise your hand if
you have a laptop.
Congratulations!
You're all multi-cloud.
And don't just trust
me, listen to this guy.
He invented Kubernetes.
"The way I think about
it: every difference
between dev/staging/prod
will eventually
result in an outage."
Did you catch that word?
Let me underline for you.
Got that?
Dev.
Dev!
Dev is an environment.
Dev is a cloud.
Dev is an environment
that you have
to replicate over and over
and over again and move.
Your laptop counts.
And this column right
here tends to be the one.
That is your experimentation
and it is something
that when your data scientists
are working on their experiment
and they go to their
production scientists
and they say, all right, it's
time for you to run this model.
They're like, I can't use any
of this stuff that you ran,
and that's not good.
And then finally, when we
think about scalability
we think about all
of these things.
Now, many people just say, OK,
it's just GPUs, TPUs, CPUs.
But really scalability is human
beings and it's skill sets
and it's number of experiments.
You need a system that can
handle all of these things.
So, Cloud Native ML--
composable, portable,
and scalable.
You know what's really
good at these things?
Containers and Kubernetes.
Except, of course, if you want
to use ML on Kubernetes today
you have to become
an expert in many,
many things and that's not good.
That's why, in December of
2017, we introduced Kubeflow.
Kubeflow, our goal is to
make it easy for everyone
to develop, deploy,
and manage portable,
distributed ML on Kubernetes.
What this looks like
is you use Kubernetes
as the unified layer.
It works on your laptop
via Minikube, Docker EE,
it works on the cloud, it works
on your training environment.
We have a Kubeflow
deployment that
describes your entire
pipeline and then
you're able to stamp out that
exact same Kubeflow deployment
in multiple locations.
Right now, in the box,
we are just at 0.1.
We have a Jupyter notebook,
we have distributed training,
we have multi-model framework,
we have lots of examples,
and best of all, we use a
tool developed by Heptio
called Ksonnet which
lets you customize
for your own packages,
including private packages that
are relevant just for yourself.
In the box today
we have this, which
includes a trainer, a model,
model validation, training
and scale, and then also
serving and monitoring.
With that, I'd like to show you
a quick demo of what it looks
like to roll out Kubeflow.
So here we are.
We're going to do
a Getting Started
and I'm going to use something.
This is a real live
demo but it types for me
so I can talk while I do it.
The first thing
we're going to do
is we're actually going
to start in Azure.
I spun up a Kubernetes cluster
last night, it's ready to go,
we switch contacts to
Azure, and now we're
going to introduce
our new Kubeflow app.
You see there?
I just type ks--
that's ksonnet--
[? init ?] and it
created the directory.
I switch into the
directory and now I'm
switching over to the context.
I create my brand new
environment locally
and I say, hey, just
letting you know,
we're going to deploy to Azure.
We set the parameter,
telling Kubeflow
that you're deploying to that
that environment I just set up,
and now we're going to select
the things that matter, right?
The first thing
I'm going to do is
I'm going to add that registry.
There's just a Kubeflow
registry out there, it's public.
I'm going install Core.
In there, it's going to go and
download 33 different files.
It's going to
install Argo, which
has our workflow
engine that's built in,
and it's going to
install TF serving.
And again, this is really,
really straightforward.
I'm just selecting
whatever makes sense
to me for my
particular environment.
I generate the deployment
and I roll it out.
That's it.
I just deployed an
entire ML pipeline,
or excuse me, it'll
deploy momentarily,
an entire ML pipeline to
this Kubernetes cluster
running on Azure.
It's taking a
little bit of time,
I apologize to the network.
But you can see here,
it's rolling out
all these various services.
It's rolling out a
dashboard, it's rolling out
a TF job operator which
extends the Kubernetes API,
it's rolling out Ambassador
as a reverse proxy.
It has a StatefulSet to
maintain your workloads
across various runs and so on.
Now, just to prove that
it's actually running there,
you can see that on
kube control I get that.
Now let's do the same thing.
Now I've done this.
Imagine that I had my
training cluster on Azure
because that's where we
had some particular data.
I want to replicate that except
now I want to do it on an AWS.
In this case, all
I need to do is
I need to switch
that, I need to create
a new environment for AWS.
I set the parameter that I'm
deploying to as being AWS
and there you go.
That's it.
Same exact thing now
running over on AWS.
And again, it'll take just
a second here to roll out.
This is in fact running live.
No videos or anything like that.
Not that there's anything
wrong with videos.
As that rolls out, let's
actually go and prove
to you that is in fact running.
Here you are.
This is the Jupyter notebook.
Jupyter is basically the
data science environment.
If I was a data
scientist, I would
have executed that one
command which they're already
familiar with how
to do very basic
installs like that
through things like pip.
In this Jupyter notebook
that I have running here,
you can see it's just a
regular old Jupyter notebook.
I'm going to train on
this and train my model
and I get an output.
Again, very, very
straightforward.
I deploy this all in
one single command.
And finally, we're going
to do the exact same thing,
except we're going
to do it to GKE.
So again, I switch it very,
very quickly and roll it out.
Three different
clouds, one command.
All I did was switch
the environments.
It knew how to pick
it up and roll it out
to these various locations.
You can see as it
picks it up here.
Here-- again, nothing.
Nothing happening.
I hit refresh on the
workloads and you
start to see them roll out.
Again, integrated with
the underlying platform.
That easy, that simple.
Able to just select the
packages that make sense to me
and move on.
So as I said, that's
only one component
of an end-to-end
machine workload.
You want to choose
all these components
but you need to
go with the data.
The reality is data needs
portability as well.
Kubernetes and Kubeflow, we
give you app portability.
But you need data
portability around where
you're using and consuming that
environment, how you share that
between the various
locations, how you make
it usable to both cloud
native and legacy apps,
and then filing how you
scale that on demand.
And with that, I'd
like to hand off
to my colleague who will
tell you all about Elastifile
and its portability.
ALLON COHEN: Thank you, David.
I'm Allon Cohen from
Elastifile and what
I'm here to tell you is
that, at the end of the day,
your models are just as good as
the data you place into them.
And that data is actually
being created everywhere.
It's being created in
data centers on premises,
it's being created at the edge.
You need to package that data.
You need to bring that data
to where you can process it.
After you process it
and create those models,
you need to take them and
bring them back to the edge
to where you can use
them for predictions
and for finding out what this
machine learning thing can
really do for you in practice.
Elastifile is just
that platform that
matches those needs of the
data for these machine learning
environments.
We provide data mobility
to bring the data
to where it's needed.
We provide shareability so
that the applications creating
the data on-prem can use
the same data platform
that Kubeflow and
TensorFlow in general
uses to process that data.
We provide usability to make
this all simple for the end
user and we provide scalability
so you can do that training
and you can process that
data as fast as you can.
And obviously, in the
cloud as in anywhere else,
time is money.
How do we do that?
We do that with two
basic platforms.
We have our
Elastifile Cloud File
System, which is a
scale-out software only,
POSIX compliant file system.
And we have
CloudConnect, which is
a system that allows you to
move the data into the cloud
and between a file
and an object layer.
The Elastifile Cloud File
System is, as mentioned, POSIX
compliant, meaning you can
mount it as an NFS mount,
as an SMB mount, to any
application that uses files.
And what application
doesn't use files?
It's scalable.
You can go to the
petabytes, you can
go to the tens of gigabytes
in throughput per second,
and it has a full
enterprise ready feature
set, including snapshots,
data reduction, replication
across environments,
as we will show you.
You can control it through
a GUI or you can even
automate the whole process that
will be demoing it to you today
through REST API controls.
And it's available
immediately at Google
through the Google
Marketplace as well will also
demonstrate in our demo.
Elastifile crosses all those
persistent storage needs
of Kubernetes environments
and Kubeflow in particular,
in these environments, the
usability, the scalability,
the shareability, and
the data mobility.
Now, we actually prepared
a great demo for you.
This was a medical demo.
It involved an medical
researcher sitting
in hospital collecting data.
That medical researcher
transferred the data
to an AI company that did the
research and the model creation
in the Google environment.
The result was transferred back
to different hospital locations
so that the people using
this data, doctors offices,
can find out through the model
where there are certain disease
is what they thought it was.
Unfortunately, our
marketing department
got a look at this demo
and they said no way,
you're not showing images of
diseases up here on the system.
We said we still want it
to be life sciences so they
said OK, life sciences,
marketing, use flowers.
So the demo I'll show
you uses flowers.
If you use a botanist that
is doing research and a model
that identifies flowers.
Whenever I say botanist,
think of a medical researcher.
And whenever I say a
florist, think of a doctor
sitting in his office.
So with that, we'll
go to the demo itself.
I'm going to show you
five simple steps.
The first two steps
are preparatory steps.
They need to be done once.
The first thing you need
to do is to get Elastifile.
As I said, that's very simple.
You saw how simple it was to
deploy Kubeflow and Elastifile
is just as simple.
You can do it directly through
the Google marketplace.
We're showing you going
to the marketplace
and deploying the
Elastifile platform.
As noted, it's a
software only platform
so it deploys anywhere.
Any region, any zone.
Wherever you can run a VM
in the Google environment
or in Amazon or in Azure as
shown, you can run Elastifile.
And the deployment it is
simple as what you saw.
You can go into
the administration
and actually create new
data but what we'll show
you is something much cooler.
We'll show you data that is
already available on-prem being
replicated to this environment.
So here is our botanist sitting
in this medical research
environment and we're
using WordPress here just
to show an application working
in a regular environment.
And what this
botanist is doing is
he's categorizing
different types of flowers,
putting them in
different buckets,
and he has a
regular application.
It's actually also
a container, but as
a regular application it
simply has a place where
it's storing its data.
In this case, the place
where it's storing his data
is a provision volume
from Elastifile.
Simply provision this NFS
for the data mobility aspect.
So the first part is a
WordPress working with data that
is sitting in a file system.
In this case it's
Elastifile but actually
it can be in any file system
sitting in your environment.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to tell the system to
replicate it into the cloud.
We're going to do
this replication not
as a one-time thing but actually
as something that is repetitive
because whenever this researcher
or the 50 other researchers
gathers new data we want
that data to go to the cloud.
We simply go to the Elastifile
GUI, we define a replication--
in this case 5 minutes--
we'll also retain two snapshots
but you can essentially retain
as many snapshots as you want.
Submit that for connection.
And within these five minutes
we have a complete set up
which has Elastifile running
across the environments
and data being replicated.
Now these data containers
can be exported as NFS.
If we exported it as NFS
WordPress in one location,
we can very simply now export
it inside Google Cloud.
So we're going to
start the fund,
this is our botanist
researching.
Oop!
I don't know if you
caught that but he just
found a new malignant flower.
And this is something that he
wants to categorize and put it
in his system.
And as you can see he's simply
using his own application--
again, in this
example, WordPress--
and he's going to
use that application
to identify this new flower.
It's a rose.
It's a new type of rose that
was unknown to the field before
and he just added
it to his data.
Now, all that would
have been useless
if it was just sitting inside
his lab, but as you recall,
we have set up the system
so that automatically
whenever new data
is created that data
is being shipped to the
Google Cloud environment.
As you'll see, because we're
replicating every five minutes,
essentially immediately
that data is available.
The system makes sure that it
is only replicating the new data
so that you're not wasting
throughput in either direction.
It identified that
there is no new data.
It moved that data into an
Elastifile provisioned data
container inside the cloud and
we can simply mount that data
container using NFS.
We see that all of
the new images that
were used by our researchers
have been immediately
brought up to the
Google environment
so that if a new
training is being done,
and if we want to improve our
model, all of the new data
is available there.
So that is exactly
what we'll do now.
The beauty of
containerized environments
is that connecting them
to a distributed file
system such as Elastifile
is a very simple thing to do
and where you're going to use
the capabilities of Kubeflow
and very simply now within
the Google environment
create new provision volumes.
We're going to show you that
just as you can provision
volumes from local storage,
which is not scalable,
you can provision volumes
from an interface mount such
as Elastifile,
which is scalable,
and we can be accessed by as
many parts as you need simply
because NFS provides a
multi-reader/multi-writer
capability into
these environments.
In the case of Elastifile,
also scalable and available
across different environments.
Now all that's essentially
left for us to do
is to run TensorFlow on the
data that we have exposed
inside Google and we're going
to simply look at the jsonnet
and show you that we
defined the data as being
sourced from the new
Elastifile provision volumes.
We are also adding a new
volume and that volume
is essentially where we'll
take the resulting model.
It's called here train out.
The train out model will also
be placed on an Elastifile data
containers because as
you will see shortly
we want to then use that data
in different environments.
We have everything set
up and we're simply
going to run the model.
But before doing that
we'll just show you
that there is nothing
inside the TF out right now
because we haven't run
it just yet, but we will.
And running it is
a simple command
of executing in
ksonnet applying the TF
job that we've just created.
We write apply and we apply
it and a job is created.
We can grab that job and see
it's up here for the 11 seconds
that we just ran it.
We can see that the pod is
being created in our Kubernetes
cluster.
And this is a small demo
so we're using one part,
but essentially, as Kubernetes
can grow the number of pods,
Elastifile can grow in the
back end, the storage side,
and handle as much
bandwidth with as much IOPS
as you would need
in the environment.
We'll take a look and
see that this is running.
You can either look at the
logs or use the beautiful GUIs
provided through Kubeflow.
It is indeed running.
You can monitor either
through API or through the GUI
the data being used
over Elastifile.
In this case, as we said it's
a very small demo, but again,
the Elastifile
environment can grow
to millions of IOPS and
tens of gigabytes per second
because you do want to
complete this training as
fast as possible.
All of this training
is happening
on the very latest data
that appeared in the cloud.
We just completed
updating the model.
Again, it's very nice
that we have a new model
but we want to take that
model to where it's useful.
So we're going to do
just as we did before,
a replication, this time
of the TF out volume.
Taking the results
and replicating it
into a third environment.
This can be another
region in Google,
this can be back to on-prem,
this can be anywhere
with two clicks.
We are replicating our
model and this makes sure,
because it's a synchronous
replication that's constantly
happening, that the model users
have the very latest model.
And the model, as you recall,
has the very latest data.
NFS again.
So no matter what
your application
is that is going
to run this model,
you can simply make
a new directory.
This time the directory
will be from GCP
because we transferred
that data from GCP
and we can mount our NFS
volume into that directory.
Once we mounted this
volume that was replicated,
we are assured that the data
is available for our processes
wherever we're
going to run them.
This can be an IoT environment.
And this can be
multiple environments
where we send that model to.
And there is our model and data.
Our florist just saw this
horrible malignant flower
in one of his
patients and is going
to check whether that
is indeed a rose.
In this case, we're running
a simple Python script that
uses the model to do a
prediction and with 99%
we're assured that
this is a rose
because the model
that we're using
was retrained on the very
latest data in the field.
So there you have it.
A storage platform
that enables you
to complement all of the
cross-Cloud capabilities
and cross-environment
capabilities of Kubeflow
and TensorFlow.
Back to you, David.
DAVID ARONCHICK: So as you can
see, Kubeflow truly is portable
and it supports all of the
portability of something
just like Elastifile to help
you move your data as well.
This is GCB next.
If we were just doing Kubeflow
0.1, that's not interesting.
Let's do something cooler.
Let's introduce Kubeflow 0.2.
Kubeflow 0.2 takes all the
work that we've done up to date
and extends it even further.
Some of these are new
and improved components
with some really
advanced stuff I'll
be showing in just second,
platform integrations,
specifically taking
advantage of different clouds
that we deploy to, and a
much simplified getting
started experience.
Advanced features.
One of the things
that we really wanted
to do when it came to Kubeflow
was make it a platform.
We didn't just want
to be providing
all of these solutions.
We wanted to let you pick and
choose platform components that
came from outside, that
came from other companies,
in this case H2O.
They had a great demo yesterday.
If you weren't there,
you can watch it online,
but basically they're
using Kubeflow
to take care of a lot
of the core components
and then they're
differentiating and it
looks like this basically.
Where you have a CPU
that's provided underneath,
you have Kubernetes and Kubeflow
as a layer on top of that,
and then you're able to
distribute the unique
components of H2O-- both the
closed source and the open
source version--
to run on top of it.
And then people can build and
engage at that higher level.
They never even have to think
about what they're running on.
That's part of the essence of
what we provide with Kubeflow.
Second, we have a
hyperparamater tuner.
For those that don't
know, one of the most
complicating and annoying
things about building a model
is really tuning
your hyperparameters.
How big your batch is, how
many epochs you should run,
what your targets should
be, and things like that.
In Kubeflow right
now, we have a brand
new alpha component
called katib,
which is based on the same
work that we do at Google
around hyperparameter tuning.
It's an open source version
and it's all checked in.
You can see here,
this is just a GIF
of running through how
you might experiment in
a whole variety of ways
directly inside Kubeflow
to explore the most
efficient hyperparameters
for your system.
And then finally, we want
to talk about PyTorch.
A lot of people can
make the assumption
that Kubeflow means
TensorFlow only.
That flow really means
machine learning flow
and we really are
deeply committed
to many, many
different frameworks.
We want to make it
very explicit here
PyTorch is absolutely supported.
It's in alpha right now and we
expect to hit beta very soon.
And to swap it out
here, were those steps
that you saw earlier, to
swap it out you literally
say I'm going to cross that
out and I'm going to swap it.
Presto, you're
now using PyTorch.
Second, I want to talk
about Platform Integrations.
One of the things you
saw with Elastifile
is that Elastifile just did
the work under the hood.
It just surfaced a
persistent volume
claim to Kubernetes and
Kubeflow knew how to use that.
That's something that's very
fundamental to Kubeflow.
We don't want to do the work.
Think about your various clouds.
This cloud has A and this
cloud has B, that's great.
As long as you surface those
elements to Kubernetes,
we're good.
And for that, it looks
something like this.
We want to support
the things that
are specific to your cloud
around security, data
exfiltration prevention,
Identity Aware Proxy.
Second, we want to support
a unique Cloud-specific
Infrastructure.
Maybe FPGA, GPU, TPU, things
like pre-emptible VMs.
And then finally
Kubernetes extensions,
where people don't
fork Kubernetes
but they take advantage of the
extensibility of Kubernetes
to provide unique solutions
for their customers.
These would be things like
node pools and auto scaling
clusters.
Now to be clear,
Kubeflow already
supports all of these today.
We do it right now
on GKE but there's
nothing specific about
Kubeflow and GKE.
It just happens that the GKE
team saw this opportunity
and built a number of solutions
and connectivity for us.
This is absolutely
supported anywhere
that Kubernetes is compliant.
Specifically, I want
to call out two things.
First, TPU Acceleration.
TPU is Google's Tensor
Processing Unit.
It's designed to make processing
machine workloads very, very
fast.
In this case, an
example is around
using a number of
image processing.
Before, on a number
of TPUs, you might
get through about 900,000
images per second and with TPUs
it's almost twice as
fast at 1.7 million.
Similarly, cost
to reach accuracy
when you're doing machine
learning workloads, your number
one goal is to reach accuracy.
In this case, to
reach 75% accuracy,
total dollars when you're
running on non-TPUs
is about $129.
On TPUs it's less than
half as much. $55.
So both faster
and a lower price.
Second, auto scaling clusters.
This is probably
the number one thing
that we hear when it comes to
machine learning workloads.
Data scientists know
data, they understand
what their needs
are, but they don't
want to think about
infrastructure at all.
And so an example here
is, My model works great,
the data scientist says.
I want six nodes.
So they ask their IT
Ops person to do it
but their IT Ops person
has a lot of things to do
and that's not great.
She's very patient.
But finally the IT Ops
person distributes it,
creates those six nodes, and
passes it back to the data
scientist to execute.
Data scientist does her
work and then she's done.
She walks away.
She says, Great, I'm
on to my next problem.
Unfortunately, they
forgot to turn it off
and that's lots of money
and that's not great.
Again, this is something where
you have two different people
working in two different ways.
What you really want is
to let the data scientist
describe what happens
and let Kubernetes
take care of the rest.
So that's where we get to auto
scaling TensorFlow for jobs.
The data scientist
describes what they need.
CPU, RAM accelerators,
and so on.
The TPU jobs then
provision themselves--
and by the way they delete
themselves when they're done--
and scale back down.
Please do remember to save
your logs externally to that.
And then finally they cap based
on maximum scale parameters.
Your data scientists can't go
and say, I want 10,000 nodes.
What that looks like is this.
The data scientist goes
and they say, OK, I'm
ready to roll out my job.
Here it is.
This is an abbreviated version.
I'll show you what a real one
looks like in just a second.
They say, I want six.
I want one CPU, I want one
GPU for each of the nodes,
and here's the
container to go and run.
Kubernetes auto-provisions that,
including attaching the GPUs.
Job is done, nodes
delete themselves,
and the IT Ops person finds
out cool stuff about YouTube
during that process.
Actually, IT Ops person
are going and working
on really hard things.
They're just not
dealing with things
that the data scientist
take care of themselves.
So with that, let me demo
it for you really quickly.
OK.
We will pop over here.
Here you are.
This is the YAML that you
might use for an auto scaling
cluster.
It looks like this.
Like I said, this is
literally all that's required.
You can see here I want six
replicas, I want CPU and a GPU,
and we will get nodes.
You can see here I
just have three nodes.
Control create -F and I'm
going to create my training.
That's it.
The data scientist has
now submitted her job
to the cluster and the clusters
are going to go and create it.
Now I'm going to show
you this and you're
going to say, wait,
where are the nodes?
Well the problem is is that
it takes about a minute.
You don't want wide ranging
nodes spin-up and spin-down.
So what we'll do is
we'll get the pods
and I will show you
that you can see
here all six are
created and are pending
and we will describe the pod.
You will see here at the
bottom it says insufficient.
So what I'd like to
do is let's swap back
and we'll come back and
check in on this in a second
because we'll do another
demo in a second.
Then finally, we want
to do Simplified Setup.
I know that's just six total
commands for setting up
Kubeflow but that's
boring and terrible.
Who would want to
do six commands?
How about one, say your version,
two, download a script--
in this case deploy .sh If you
already have it on your system
you don't even need to redo it.
Three, you deploy.
Great.
Now you're at one command.
One command is better than
six, even I know that.
Let's swap over and I'll show
you what that looks like.
And let's see how
we're doing here.
We get our nodes and
it's still coming up.
We'll come back to
that in a second.
And here we are.
Easy setup ls.
I left some old stuff here
so we'll just get rid of you.
All right.
You can see here deploy.sh.
This is a lot of
stuff but really
it's pretty straightforward.
It asks for your IP address
and things like that
but this is the important
part that you're
going to want to care about.
You can detail right
there in your deploy.sh
the packages that you want
but everything else is
taken care of for you.
And in this case, I
want to deploy it all.
I've downloaded it
already and it's done.
That's it.
Everything that you saw before
is now being setup as we speak.
That is exactly what
our intention was.
To make it that easy to
set up Kubeflow over time.
Let's go back to see what
our node situation is
and you can see
they're [? out. ?]
So it has been
provisioned and it's just
a matter of coming up and
attaching to the Kubernetes
cluster.
You can see there we have the
nodes that we had originally
and then we added
those six that were
specific to the
particular workload.
That's Kubeflow.
That is what we're
working on to make machine
learning on Kubernetes easy.
You didn't see
bespoke solutions,
you didn't see us having to
extend Kubernetes or fork it
in some specific way.
You also didn't see
cloud-specific tech.
Everything you saw
there is surfaced
to Kubernetes through standard
extension points and that
really is key.
And you didn't see forking
of the Kubernetes API.
The Kubernetes CRDs are designed
for this kind of extension
and are absolutely
critical for what we use.
We've had great momentum
since we got started.
Over 1,000 commits, 100
community contributors,
20 plus companies
contributing including
very, very significant folks.
[INAUDIBLE],, Alibaba,
Cisco, obviously Google,
Uber contributed
MPI and Horovod,
we have Pachyderm for
doing data processing,
and you can see many of
the other folks there.
And the reality is is that this
is what we're trying to do.
As you saw, our goal
is to get to a place
where data scientists can
operate at that next layer up.
They shouldn't have
to understand anything
about their underlying
infrastructure.
They should focus on
the work that they're
trying to do because
they're experts at that.
They're not experts
in infrastructure.
And it is absolutely our
goal that within five years,
every paper in the world, every
research, every experiment
in the world, comes with a
Kubeflow deployment, a pipeline
that describes how to run
that model and deploy from all
the way from data all the way up
to production, and sample data.
And with those three we think we
can make dramatic improvements
to the overall
reproducibility problem.
And really, our goal
is to empower these.
The people not here.
The people who don't know
anything about Kubernetes.
We want to give them tools
to make their own decisions
with their own data.
And we are just getting started.
Kubeflow 0.3 is due in weeks,
where weeks is about 12.
Our roadmap, we're
really marching
through getting
towards 1.0 and we
want to bring a lot of
those alpha features
that you saw forward into beta.
But also we want to keep
pushing higher level.
That hyperparameter
tuning right now,
it requires a
little bit of code.
Our hope is that we
can accomplish that
without any code whatsoever.
We want to provide job operators
right now to support PyTorch.
It was a little bit
of work but we want
to support all the frameworks--
XGBoost and Caffe and MXNet
and all those various things.
And we're going to do that
through a standard extensible
framework.
And then finally we want to get
to things like Click to Deploy.
Again, data scientists
shouldn't even have to see code.
They shouldn't even have
to use a deploy script.
They should be able to do
that behind the scenes.
Or, better yet, tell us,
because we really are listening.
It is a wide open community.
We want to respond to
wherever you're taking it
and the more scenarios that you
come up with the better it is.
It will help guide the project.
And with that, there's
lots of places to connect.
Please reach out to me,
reach out to Elastifile,
reach out wherever you'd
like because we really
are ready to hear
about how you'd
like to use this and
bring it to [INAUDIBLE]..
[MUSIC PLAYING]